[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making headlines with the
economist Cara Malone and editor of The
Courier David Clegg they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's take a look at what is on those
front pages we'll start with the eye
boosting election hopes for the Tories
the PM is level with kirstama as
preferred leader of the country paper
reports the telegraph leads on plans
being drawn up by Mr sunac to expand the
windfall tax on energy firms in an
effort to fill the UK's fiscal black
hole the guardian has a different take
highlighting the bumper profits recorded
by shell on the day that the UN finds
there is no credible way to limit Global
temperature rises to 1.5 degrees
as the global economy slows and cost
pressures Mount the Ft reports that more
than 550 billion dollars has been
slashed from the value of U.S tech
companies
Royals in despair as the Metro's top
story it's focusing on concern among the
royal family about the contents of
Prince Harry's coming memoir
the same story on the front page of the
Daily Mail
well the sun reports that Prince William
will not travel to Qatar to watch
England play in the World Cup next month
the front of the mirror shows a picture
of the convicted sex to fix child sex
trafficker Gillette Maxwell going on a
run in the ground to the jail where she
uh is facing 20 years
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you see on your screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch along with us
well I'm pleased to say we're joined
tonight by the columnist Carol Malone
and the editor of The Courier David
Clegg
and there they are Carol David good
evening to you thank you for being with
us lovely Tavia both here all right
let's dive straight in straight and then
shall we are Carol will start with um
the eye which picks upon a pole that
shows that uh sunac coming in as leader
of the conservative party and the Prime
Minister has given the conservative
party some kind of election hope
yes yes it's a good story it's it's it
does give the toys because what it's
basically saying is that um people
believe that he will be better with the
economy and with taxes than secure style
wouldn't because that is true you know
we know him to be an expert on on
financial matters
um the poll however does say that um
that uh he levels with Stormer as the
preferred leader
um which is pretty good considering he's
only been in power for a handful of days
but but it what it does say is the bad
news but Mr
um I'm very aware that the light is
shining on my glasses oh you're doing
fine don't worry Carol it's all right
you know what it is I can see the
spotlight related anyway but the bad
news is if an election was called
tomorrow
um so the labor would win by a landslide
which is not good news but we kind of
know that and and you know we can't well
you know we we take our guidance from
pearls we know that they're not the case
if Rishi does well in the next six six
months six months to a year well then
you know he's got a very good hope of
the Tories winning the next election
that is of course if he can keep his
pardon the control and stop them
cannibalizing each other but it's it's
quite a good Pearl considering that he's
only been in power for a few days what
it does do this poll of course it's a
big blow for um a comeback for Boris in
2024. it is saying that that people just
don't want that to happen but um you
know who knows you know with with Boris
you know you never know but it but it is
good and and you know London sunak are
currently looking
um you know at ways to to fix the
economy there and although although um
Mr Hunt is the chancellor not entirely
sure he'll be having much to do with the
upcoming budget in November I think he's
um I think Russia would be Chancellor by
a proxy because his plan will already be
in place now he knows what he's got to
do um and he's already hinted as to what
he's going to do so yeah let's wait soon
yeah and David I suppose it's difficult
for the labor party isn't it because for
the past sort of six months or so
they've been really pushing this idea
that they are the ones who are
physically uh responsible and that was
sort of evidenced by what we saw the
disastrous mini budget but quick change
a leader and it's all changed around in
The public's opinion apparently
I I think given the chaos of the last
few weeks if the poll ratings hadn't
improved with this change of prime
minister it would have been a major
surprise given the uh what must be go
down in history is the most disastrous
budget uh in the history of the UK the
impact it had on the markets but also uh
talking of the pool the impact it had on
conservative poll readings so I think
given that Rishi sunak had been
Chancellor before it is something that
people associate himself with I think
this will be a harder uh a harder Target
now for the labor party to reinstate
themselves as the party of fiscal
responsibility because that of course is
not something that is necessarily
traditionally been associated with labor
I think that is going to be more of a
challenge for them now there is of
course the issue that Rishi sunak as
prime minister and D Jeremy Hunt as
Chancellor are facing what is the most
foreboding Financial picture for many
years certainly since the the crash so
they are going to have a very difficult
time and they're the ones who are in
power they're the ones who are going to
have to make these decisions these
decisions many of which are going to be
painful that are going to be unpopular
so Weller the uh Financial prudence and
the Trust In Rishi sunak to steer the
economy remains that way as we get
through uh what's going to be a very
difficult winter and through 2023 that
remains to be seen yeah and I'll say
with you uh David to go to the Daily
Telegraph because exactly on that these
decisions that have to be made the
telegraph reporting and this will be a
manner to the labor party that is
planning to perhaps expand that windfall
tax which is exactly what labor had been
calling for for the past few months
yes indeed uh and that would be I I
think that would probably be a popular
uh policy I think it is a it is a very
distinct change intact from uh the less
trust racing this the idea would be not
only that they extend it past the cutoff
of December 2025 but also perhaps I
think it's set at 25 at the minute to
increase the rate of the levy so they
would be generating even more money uh
from these big energy companies I think
given the record profits announced Again
by shell today uh that that is something
that I think will probably prove uh
popular that would maybe uh win support
across the political divide at this
point so I wouldn't be surprised if that
is something we see the uh conservative
party and Rishi sunak uh considering as
they face these numbers and have to plug
this massive spending Gap so I I think
that's probably an easy win there
because it's not something labor can
criticize them for it's something that
will prove popular with the public uh
and it shows also that they're trying to
generate money as well as just uh
moving on to spending cuts which I guess
is the concern from people uh very
worried about how they're going to pay
their their bills this winter yeah right
as Dave's right Carl isn't it the idea
of that kind of tax on those big profits
is quite popular and uh which at least
trust was ideologically against it but
what does this tell us about the way
Rishi sunaki is willing to sort of move
with the times and and try and plug that
Gap that there is in the finances
if he takes a big chunk from all the big
energy companies you know all he has to
say to them is you know these are tough
times you guys have been making sky-high
profits for X amounts of years there has
been no cap on those profits so for this
year this year alone maybe even for next
year depending on what the climate is
like this is we're going to take a
percentage of your profits and you know
what can those energy companies do they
know that they make the profits they've
made have been obscene there has to be
some give with them and I reckon he
could fill that 40 billion hole fairly
quickly with some money off of the oil
companies and then maybe he doesn't have
to to hit the people of the country
quite so hard because why this poll
we've just seen today says that you know
people you know they like the way he
handles the economy the bottom line is
with Liz truss's budget people are going
to get a cut in their income tax this
way they're going to get a big rise in
their income tax because there's still
this National Insurance with order with
you know ordinary income tax they're
going to take a hit and where people you
know it's it's it's a very tough thing
for people they know it's the sensible
thing to do to have a tax rise when
times are hard but you know we are in
the midst of the biggest cost of living
crisis ever you know we've seen people
today I think it's on one of the places
could be the guardian today people have
been rushing today to register their
their meter reading so that they get
because this is the day at midnight
tonight this is when all the the prices
go up when it becomes something like
Adam is a 1900 quid a year uh for that's
the average price of energy well that
goes up that goes to that at midnight
tonight so people have been hanging on
until the last minute to register their
meter readings to get as long as they
can on the cheapest possible rate this
shows how desperate people are to save
every penny so when he does put taxes up
as he is going to in November that's
when his popularity may take a dive
again so yes as much as he can take from
these oil companies is a good thing okay
let's move on to the next story before
we go to break guys and Carol I'll stay
with you for this one this on the front
page of the guardian and this is one of
of the issues one of the sort of
landmines that which you see that may
have laid for himself by bringing suela
bravaman back in to government six days
after she was sacked resigned over a
security breach
yes yeah and and labor are kicking up
it's not just about it's not just about
what happened last week where she was
supposed to have sent a a private
document she brought in a serial code
but this is also about a leak it
involves a leak uh when she was attorney
general
um involving MI5 and labor was stirring
this up and I know why they're doing it
because and I suspect the Civil Service
are doing it too they didn't want so
well a problem and the blob if you like
have their own agenda they know what Sue
Ella Bravo is going to do on issues like
immigration she has vowed to cut the
chapel Crossings and she's she's going
to do it in quite a tough way so I think
there are many people who don't want Sue
Ella bravaman in situ but also there's a
there's a view around today that keeping
her in that job placate the right of the
party it keeps them happy and that's
what sunak is trying to do now that all
that talk last week of him applying a
cabinet of the big Talent well what
necessarily a capital as a big Talent it
was it was a coalition of the warring
factions and he was appeasing them
giving them jobs to shut them up so he
can unite the party again and suela
Bravo is very very popular with the
right because of the stuff she has said
um I think she has to temper her
language a bit I saw an interview that
she did a couple of months ago where she
was talking about her big dream is to
see
um a plain load of migrants go to Rwanda
now you know while we know that that
that she wants to if she wants to
implement that system to talk about it
being her dream is a little bit silly
and I can see why that would have said
some people but you know I think she's
tough I think the Civil Service don't
want to there and labor certainly don't
want it there okay Carol David thank you
for that they've not got time to come to
you God to break but I'll start off with
you next when we come back after these
advertisements Carol David wait right
where you are now plenty more from the
Press few preview to come including this
on the front of the Daily Mail their
headline Royals dreading Harry's rope
and unflinching book
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back you are watching
The Press preview I'm pleased to say
we're still joined by Carol Malone uh
and the editor of The Courier David
Clegg uh Carol David thanks for staying
with us through that break right David
let's pick up with you on the front page
of the Guardian I mean a picture says it
all really doesn't it and the headline
no way back this is another terrifying
report coming out of the U.N on the face
on the extent of the climate crisis
yes and I think one of the interesting
things about the tone around it now is
there is a sense of the fetism about it
and I think that was kind of underlying
today we have not only have the the
shell report or the shell profits we
also have the um the fact that uh Rishi
sunak is not planning to attend cop 27
and one thing I've been struck by in
particular is is the complete change in
tone and sentiment about dealing with
the climate crisis from a year ago it
was it was almost exactly a year ago
that there were glass there were Gallery
in Glasgow for cop 26 and it felt like
it was at the top of the political
agenda this uh absolute emergency for
the first time in the way it hadn't
really uh been before since then a
couple of things have changed I think uh
the most pressing probably the the war
in Ukraine and the issue with Russia so
there is this sense that that worry
about energy security uh the global
Dynamics behind that has I think changed
the priorities of of the of the
politicians across across Europe and the
rest of the West really and and that is
shown by the I think that's highlighted
vividly by the fact that Rishi sunak is
not even planning to go we know that uh
King Charles uh has said already that
he's he's not going and I just don't
think that it would be feasible that
would have been the situation a year ago
instead the case is that uh
that we know this emergency is coming
the un uh that the U.N report is is
absolutely Bleak reading it's saying
there's no credible pathway it talks
about uh preparations for this being
willfully inadequate that there will
have to be wide scale a widespread
social change across the world if we're
trying to get to what what what is
actually a fairly modest Target uh
compared to what needs to be done but I
think at the political widdle will
towards us uh has sat over the last year
and there's not much sign of that
changing yeah and Carol I've thought
from you on this we haven't got loads of
time left but obviously
the job he's got he's got the biggest
job of any peacetime prime minister you
you name it the economy you know raging
inflation rate raging interest rates uh
the cost of living crisis all these
things he's got to deal with and and
he's he has said clearly that this is
not about a change of priority he's
saying that it's it's he's not
downgraded climate change as as a
priority he's just saying that he's got
a truckload of work to do here at this
moment in time and he can't be there to
do that as well he's got so many things
to put in place he's got to steady the
markets he's got to make them confident
again and we don't have a long time to
do that we've got a matter of weeks
we've taken a massive battering on on a
world stage in terms of our our
credibility as as an economy so he's got
some stuff to do but he has said
absolutely clearly that it's it's not a
downgrade and then he's going to keep
tabs on what's going on there and let's
not forget Britain is only responsible
for one percent of global emissions some
of the countries that are going there to
I think there's China the US the Indians
they until they get their act together
nothing we do in this country is going
to matter so I think that what he's got
on his plate now is is you know I don't
think it's a it's a desertion of his
duty towards climate change that's all
okay Carol David really appreciate that
great discussion stay with us could you
be with us for the next hour as well and
we're back with you very very soon